we're at the end of the very first
recruitment murder Co saliva then I'm
absolutely buzzing had a room happily
recruiters business owners 60 people
turned up it's the first one I wasn't
sure how to how big to go for the first
one but I wanted to make sure that there
was value that it was a bit different it
wasn't just a typical recruitment event
people enjoyed it it was fun also got a
lot of value out of it
so I'm really pleased take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
it was ten times better than I ever
imagined so much energy from everybody I
felt like people really wanted to be
here and they were like hungry for it
about like this
[Music]
I think the whole thing so I been really
enjoyable but a lot of like anyone from
like beginning of their career tonight
that's why their career like business
owners accept you everything between now
I'm poised yeah really cool it's quite
nice to spend time with people though on
life something to you I think it's
important spending time with like-minded
people
[Music]
I think you learn things here that you
might be able to learn from a video from
a message actually looking somebody in
the eye is so important in what we do
but being able to do that with
like-minded people and actually experts
they're able to take real things to
learn from is something you don't get a
chance to do every day
[Music]
the people that you're going to meet the
put the stories that you're going to
hear they're all things that people have
experienced that are going to help you
to be able to become a better recruiter
whichever aspects of recruitment and
you're looking for advice on you can get
it from this podcast and also just the
feeling of knowing that there's people
that have been in that position that
have been through what you're going
through that can help you to get to
where you want to get to here so this is
the first of many recruitment
rollercoaster live events if you liked
what you saw and you want to be part of
a community that's willing to share
ideas share challenges be vulnerable
have a laugh have fun then keep your
eyes peeled there's going to be many
more to come
[Music]
you